[Music]
well I'm sorry to say there's a bit of a
controversy brewing backstage here at
the Conan show and brewing is actually
an app term to use because it involves
an espresso machine and one mr. jordan
shlonsky investigators crime now
starting off with mr. John Coto how are
you John doing great
tell us about the espresso machine
people are saying that there's an
expensive new machine in that Jordan
only lets a few people have access to it
now Jordan loves you Italy and in fact
may believe that he's Italian even
though his last name is slanting do you
know what Jordan does on the show
not really are you worried at all for
Jordan telling me this no why he's so
like dead he doesn't he's dead there's
like nothing nothing fazes him okay I'm
headed back into Jordan's Lansky's
office to confront him about this
espresso machine his office is not
accessible like everyone else's it's
hidden away that was Jordans choice
let's find out
and you got to go through here Jordan
put on the Brian here first of all your
office is a mess okay have you been on
borders yet you have an espresso machine
here there is an espresso machine here
what's the difference between what you
say don't I have it probably no I don't
have it it's here doesn't mean I have it
what do you mean
I understand I use it but I don't have
it have it implies that I own it I don't
own it
oh you don't own it no I don't own it
who purchased the machine you actually
own it
you purchased everything in this office
I did yes did that buy in this Italian
almond biscotti no that was free this is
a free biscotti yes miss Coco Putney
it's a piece dr. biscotti that would be
if there's more than one there's only
one would you take me out and show me
the espresso machine please yes this is
Lavazza blue LB 2312 espresso machine
the machine retails for between five and
seven hundred dollars mmm-hmm it's
expensive machine
I suppose that's relative error espresso
machines that cost five thousand dollars
why did you go for one of those I didn't
want to stay your money needlessly do
you feel that you were forthcoming about
the location of the machine and that
everyone was welcome to use it I want
you to understand that it's not my
responsibility before coming in to make
announcements of it at times I suggested
his purchase be made I'm not its
caretaker it's Wrangler do you think you
find that it's do you find this ring do
you find it at all interesting that the
machine is located when you see how many
steps
three four five six seven seven feet
actually a little more because I've got
big feet and ladies do the math I'm
noticing right now that the instructions
on the machine are in Italian do you
think that's at all off-putting to
people who want to use the machine and
don't speak Italian I think you're
making the assumption that I chose the
display language furthermore Italian is
a beautiful language and I don't see the
problem with having Italian instructions
on the machine so you made a decision
for the group yes I did the way
Mussolini made a lot of decisions having
me if things running smoothly I've been
very welcoming of everybody to use that
net rights versus very welcoming the
Fuehrer was behind fewer doors in his
bunker in 45 I'm gonna make that clear I
had to walk through I believe seven
doors to get here you could not hide a
coffee machine better if Osama bin Laden
was cringing near this coffee machine
he'd be alive today because no one would
ever have found him I take it this is
the infamous sign espresso 101 you wrote
these instructions I used this as an
opportunity to educate the staff is
largely American on what a proper
Italian espresso should be I'm noticing
that you talk about United States and
Americans almost with contempt do you
realize that you're from Buffalo you
have a derisive tone towards these
Americans at the rates of tone towards
the quality of coffee served in the US
you hate an American coffee I've never
had a sip of American coffee you won't
drink coffee in this country I don't
believe in drip brew coffee
Jordan quick question what are your
responsibilities on this show I have
various duties my title is Associate
Producer it's the greatest mountain
answer I've ever heard
this is my title care to come clean what
is it you do here various production
related tasks if used the word various
one more time I'm having you arrested
what is your job
Associate Producer what do you do when
you come into work varies from time Mary
various this is my title
you are one crafty fake Italian what I'm
going to do is remove this machine for a
period of time I'm gonna replace it with
this machine this is the windmere as far
as I know it's not even a coffee I think
they made lawn mowers until they went on
a business it's dirty it's old it has a
simple on/off switch in English because
god Bless America
you son of a and you make your
coffee I think this is blood you will
make your coffee out of this machine
that's right
drip coffee you will drink it for a week
well my investigations complete
punishments been meted out this is Conan
O'Brien
[Music]
[Applause]
Jory's Lansky and his new coffee machine
ladies and gentlemen
we'll take a break